is this is this administration
or just what i mean the border's open
the border's open the borders open and
also these massive immigration uh influx
into the united states put every single
most of your already outstretched
resources into a single spot which means
it's christmas for
trafficking
everywhere else yeah
bullets and guns from the north to the
from the north to the south and cash
this country is being strangled out yeah
strangled
slow slow demise there's a pillow over
the face of america right now and uh
again it's it's
this border this border crisis is making
millions and millions of dollars for
people that are just waiting for the cat
to go you know to be busy somewhere else
you know this is
tunnels there's somewhere i mean
conversation
somewhere over 50 to 60
active tunnels on the border
i talked about fully submersibles way
back in the day nobody believed me about
those that was where we've been found
wait wait wait wait wait they're using
submarines
to smuggle stuff and people and
uh
drugs drugs you wouldn't use something
as valuable as a fully submersible
summary for people because then the
people have a tendency to talk you know
yeah i came here in a summary
uh but yeah fully submersibles uh drones
uh like squadron of drones um catapults
small
cadillac oh i heard these stories they
launched them over the trebuchets
that's the first time i when i saw one i
saw one in mexicali
and
i saw and i was like that's a trebuchet
like how do you know that word i watched
kpbs i think i learned about them and so
they're flinging drugs over they fling
drug loads over they uh rc cars electric
control remote cars rc cars just speed
out there
drones tunnels
people that have uh border crossing
cards like there's a century program in
place like places like baja where people
that cross the border regularly get uh
extra verified by the us
uh and uh cartel's aware of this so they
see oh you're a century pass guy
let me put some load on the bottom of
your car because you're already trusted
traveler and that's an easy way to get
drugs into the country it's like the
thing that kids do when you're like
shopping at a 7-eleven and then your
friend puts a candy bar in your hood so
you don't know what's happening and you
walk just like normally out of the store
and you're not acting suspicious and the
kid walks up and it's like yeah yeah
that only with a you know kia coke
you know that that happens a lot on the
border basically kilogram of coca-cola
yeah just a two-liter i guess right yeah
some booger sugar uh it's it's a
it's a classic story a lot of people get
caught like that and it's
again these guys are just
looking for holes in the already whole
written
wall
um so trump was right
he was right about what the securing the
border in general i mean securing the
border
specifically you uh so what you're
saying is trump is correct and we should
build a big beautiful 30-foot concrete
wall from sea to shining sea i mean i
think a wall is not feasible
i'm kidding
but i mean like in terms of like
focusing on the borders and we've got
serious problems here yeah so there's
serious problems with things coming from
the us into mexico that's part of the
issue it's not just things coming out
what's happening the other way uh
bullets bullets guns right
uh well to be fair obama gave those
people those guns so that was that was a
fair deal that's the fast and furious
program it was bad that's like cia
delivering weapons to i mean i
don't know i don't know a lot about the
fast and furious on the u.s side i just
know it was a program started by the
bush administration specifically and
then continuing on with the obama
administration
uh two of my friends were killed by some
of those guns wow fn57 pistols one of
them was coming out of his house
with his daughter in the back seat and
his wife
uh he him and his wife got killed and
the daughter lost her arm um
the kids that shot them
um had fm57 pistols uh 18 and 19 year
olds you worked for you you were working
border security for mexico though i was
i was not working border security i was
working generalized regional security
basically but a lot of our work was
basically working against people that
were trying to get stuff through the
border we're trying to get things from
the us
how does that work with the cartels then
right because the government's certainly
not in complete control no uh i mean
there's there's
there's really realistically there's no
border security in in mexico there's a
there's a place where people cross by
and there's more agents but they're
looking for taxable goods they're not
looking for
every now and then they'll get
contraband people trying to smuggle guns
or bullets in
but they're realistically not looking to
secure the border on the mexican side
and the government itself has a case of
amnesia every six years when the new
president comes in everything gets you
know all this that was successful this
was failure everything's bad get rid of
all of it i'm gonna start this new thing
and they just change the name of the
police change the uniform and same
corrupt people
yeah they're right on yeah
that why give up it's cash yeah all
their pockets are getting grease right
that's the thing and it's i mean i went
through
two uh terms of that basically do it 12
years working down there
it's unwinnable do you think there's any
value to the us and of mexico and the
u.s of america to become one country
the whole concept of an american a north
american union
well i mean i think the u.s needs to
realize i mean i hear a lot of people
just close the border you know just pull
the wall close the border that's the
second largest trade partner right
we we could however if we annex canada
and mexico can script the canadians to
fight the cartels
sure
just send them down there put down the
fn 570
you know that's probably
well it's another funny thing
when the uh when trump was in the
presidency and then the the border was
you know a bit harder to get across
um cartel uh you know people smugglers
would just fly people to canada
oh really yeah that was like that was
one of the ways they would just fly bula
cannon and just walk down you know
clever
there there are places in canada where
you can see these videos on reddit where
it's like there'll be like a teenager
standing in between it'll be like u.s
canadian border and it's just like a
it's like a a chain link you know like
it's like a chain going across like two
orange posts
and there's no one anywhere near it
there's one part where i think it's in
minnesota
where it's the honor system you drive in
pull up to a booth go up to the booth
like it's like a little shack you go
inside pick up the phone and say hi you
give me your name and say i'm entering
the country and say okay thank you and
then you hang up and then you that's
beautiful yeah
that will never happen i think on the
southern border but it's an interesting
thing i mean it feels like it's worse
well people are just walking through
like they don't even have the phone call
they don't have a phone call
there's our there's videos uh there's
trail videos and and rancher videos in
texas of just guys and with a case on
their backs and dressed in like uh gamo
and stuff like that from cartel groups
basically armed cartel groups
in texas just you know moving around and
just coming back and
what if like what if somebody has
property
up against the border and then they see
some dude with like an ak coming from
the border crossing onto their property
do they have a right to defend their
property and stop the skies like i mean
i think they do have a right to defend
their property and they have the means
if they're in texas the problem is that
these people can get to you yeah these
people have a reach
and and their reach isn't dependent on
them crossing the border
uh another weird myth that
that americans have is that ah we don't
want they're coming into this country
they want the cartels here they're
they're coming they have been here for
years
yeah they have they have
uh blood ties into in this country they
have they're in the military they're in
the military they're in the border
patrol they're in uh they're in politics
apparently you know yeah they're about
they're everywhere um
and uh you you you this
this border this portal the border fence
and the board itself they crossed it
years back and it's a place like chicago
places like l.a
when they legalized weed uh some of
these groups had already gone into the
you know
they were already producing heat right
so
they went into the illegal weed and the
legal weed industry they did both they
were growing illegal weed and federal
lands on the us wow so
they they are here like a lot i hear a
lot of people talking about military
intervention in mexico
it's not afghanistan it's not iran and
it's not iraq
it's right there and also it's right
here
it's it's an it's if if that happens
it's an interesting
it's going to be an interesting conflict
because i don't think it's going to be
like any conflict this country has ever
fought specifically it's going to be
really close i mean they have they have
presence uh
many of these cartels have a presence in
all the big cities yeah i know there's
like graffiti all over chicago
in new york there was some big story 10
years ago about ms-13 like operating in
new york city yeah so yeah man i mean
it's it's scary um
and also the fact that uh you know
mexico has a lot of problems
but also has a lot of resources right
yeah including the
one of the largest mineable lithium
lithium deposits on the planet really
yeah are they mining it
and there was a splash water on it well
there was a there was a there was a
canadian company owned by china that
wanted to buy some of those mining
rights and that ended pretty quickly and
then right around the area where that
some of this stuff is is where the
mormon massacre happened down there
which is an interesting coincidence when
was that
ah that was about two years ago yeah
recent
um
so which is crazy because isn't that a
star trek episode what what that like
mormons from earth go find another
planet and then like an alien race kills
them and there's an incident where they
go and investigate them because mormon
massacre are we talking about next
generation next generation yeah i've
been thinking about that show today i
was into that when i was a kid i'm sorry
so you're getting me who would you be
maybe i'm misremembering what riker like
you look like him too like her all the
way number one riker and i would get
some of the data arms you know just
crush
people
okay
i'm confirming we were talking about the
lithium mining sonora largest deposit
with uh proven improvable reserves
reserves of 243.8 million tons of
probable reserves about four and a half
million tons of lithium as of 2019. if
the u.s actually goes in there into
mexico i think it's not going to be
about regime change or cartels or
terrorism it's going to be about making
batteries yeah
you guys ever put water on lithium no i
think i've seen it happen explodes right
yeah the uh it rips the hydrogen out of
the water i guess or the oxygen i can't
remember and then it heats up really
really quickly and starts on fire that's
the craziest thing splashing water is
that's on fire yeah but this is like
great school high school science class
stuff so
every now and then you'll see somebody
with a smartphone with a old battery
boom boom so when you were doing
security you're out on the border and
you you're spending a lot of time out in
the middle of nowhere in the desert and
stuff yeah sometimes yeah you're seeing
aliens
i saw a few us drones flying places
where they shouldn't be flying i was
only i was only having what i want to
say is like have you experienced like
weird things creepy things yeah i assume
the answer is yes right but i don't i
don't i don't want to make this like
obviously like bigfoot or chupacabra i
mean like literally like have there been
like weird people have you like seen
operations happening uh and weird stuff
like aliens um
weird calls from high up people you know
um telling us to you know deliver
certain people that shouldn't be
arrested you know
um
corruption of some sort but on both
sides because or undercover operations
could be yeah who knows
seeing uh seeing armed americans in
mexico working and whoa yeah aren't
mexican americans working in mexico
armed that's a thing
i've heard stories that uh
there was one story i was reading about
i don't know if you read this one like a
journalist went to el chapo's house or
whatever
you ever hear this one i think this may
have been vice it's been a long time but
apparently like
uh
maybe maybe maybe this is tops maybe
this is confidential information i can't
remember anyway but he was working with
americans his security were all north
american accent guys like top level
former military stuff like that
the new generation cartel has a training
camp somewhere in in jalisco
and
american sf
something or other
has trained them so i don't know if it's
an official
it can't be an official capacity but
some sort of former military specialized
training that's what you see out there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time